es gibt ja wirklich viele arten im
perfekten kreis zu zeichnen einmal mit
dem zirkel oder hier mit einer schablone
oder mit diesen trick nun bestimmt
einige von euch noch nicht kennen werden
mit abstand am leichtesten ist es aber
so zu erstmalig den kopf ein anderer der
ich ein paar details weg und 3 2 1 ein
kreis re 1 re 6 jeder kennt diese szene
auf spongebob aber mal spaß beiseite
menschen zeichnen halbwegs gerade linien
können schon ganz gut im kopfrechnen und
den kameras schon ganz okay aber
perfektion ist eigentlich den maschinen
vorenthalten jedoch einmal alle hundert
jahre passiert etwas erstaunliches
stellt euch für euer lehrer zieht
einfach so etwas ab er hätte sofort
respekt er macht freilich aus der
schulter er mit dem ellenbogen er um
seinen kleinen finger herum und mike
schenk aus dem handgelenk menschen die
verrückte dinge an einer tafel machten
bewegen warum auch immer
die welt und da dachte ich mir hey ich
wollte schon immer eine tafel im büro
haben und jetzt habe ich endlich die
perfekte ausrede einzukaufen kann sich
so was eigentlich jeder einfach im
internet kaufen ich finds raus tafel
werden wir den tischen gezeigt ich keine
tafel nach amazon.de amazon.com
amazon.de tafel also die ach ja schon
mir sind eher schlecht aber es gibt eine
kleine tafeln aber ich will halt
wirklich schon großes zahl die
bildschirm geil aussehen aber dieser
immer zu klein
zwei meter 20 und dem 15
das sieht eine tafel in der schule
hsg post also die tafel ist größer als
ich dachte mensch sein und er stellt
sich auch gleich mal die frage soll ich
eine aufbauen ich weiß ja nicht wie es
euch geht aber ich habe nie meinem leben
eine tafel aufgebaut und buch das
eigentlich mal eine spannende sache mal
eine tafel auszupacken ihr lernt hier
echt viel gelernt zum beispiel was alles
in der tafel verpackung 18 und zugehört
ein bisschen werkzeug also so sauber
seine dinge bei uns in der schule nie
aus wir wollten jetzt dass man den
schrauben und dübel festmacht so viel
sei gesagt habe ich nicht
ich denke dass die höhe relativ kuba ich
habe die karte für christen ono de da
macht das nicht automatisch dass das
kaufen sie greifen sind hier ist echt
das gefühl mal möglichkeiten zu haben
und die nicht zu klauen von der schule
ich weiß nicht wie lange ich gerade
nicht ein underdog
es gibt mehrere strategien bin gespannt
wie lange es dauert bis sich die kammer
an mit dieser komischen zirkel methode
wie man uns eigene handgelenk mache die
fand ich eigentlich mit am spannendsten
das erleichterte mann schwamm holen
können
also ganz ohne technik funktioniert zwar
ungefähr so ist eine dass ich noch
einmal tafeldienst hartnett
also ich verstehe schon wie es
funktioniert es sieht doch gar nicht mal
so schlecht aus wie perfekt ist das noch
lange nicht es doppelt hier schon ein
bisschen wenn ich jetzt im kreis sehen
wir den wert schon impressed ja wenn ich
jetzt nicht wissen wie das geht schon
kasse aber ist noch lang kein perfekter
kreis wie in dem video das ist aber
schon echt da das jetzt nicht so
geklappt hat probleme mit dieser taktik
nicht am wildesten kinder eigentlich
sehe potenzial musste ellbogen ran
das schon die komische technik oder du
bist noch mit der methode von mike
schenk weil der macht einfach nur zu aus
dem handgelenk
[Musik]
kannst du mal wie du willst ein chrysler
kreis selbst sogar von wie gesagt du
sollst vorstellen den öfter im kopf
machen und dann ins internet zu malen
hat sich noch ein päckchen kreis gesehen
im leben mai kreuth hat er immer wieder
gemacht haben fünf millionen klicks und
ich hab das in rentenfonds tragischer
probiert mal diese weltmeister mit wurde
aus der schulter beiden sind auch nicht
mehr das was er mal war
[Musik]
trotz der vielen kaputten kreiden
entscheide ich mich bei der schulter mit
wurde zu bleiben und sie zu
perfektionieren ganz einfach weil ich
diese am beeindruckendsten finde das
ganze zu meistern bedeutet in meinem
fall stumpfe wiederholung bis mein arm
weh tut damit meine übung nicht ständig
vom tafel putzen unterbrochen wird
zeichne ich teilweise 50 kreise am stück
und bekomme ein gefühl dafür in welchen
ecken diese vielleicht noch etwas mehr
oder weniger krümmung bräuchten um dem
ideal näherzukommen
erstaunlich ist es wie sehr die kreide
meine hände austrocknet plötzlich hat
alles was ich anfasse extrem viel grip
aus dem gleichen grund aus dem kletterer
ihre hände mit kreide bedecken überall
an jedem objekt im zimmer ist gerade so
viel dass ich mich frage ob es überhaupt
gesund ist für einen lehrer der große
teile seines lebens an einer tafel
verbringt und diesen stau womöglich eine
art mit kleiner fun fact meine recherche
dazu hat übrigens ergeben dass kreide
einfach aus gips besteht dem tatsächlich
zur staub verringerung oft milcheiweiß
hinzugefügt wird weshalb das für
allergiker gar nicht so unproblematisch
ist ob kreide staub einatmen nun
allgemein um gesund ist ist kaum
erforscht aber gut stelle ich mir das
nicht vor
[Musik]
übung macht den meister und so schaffe
ich langsam sehr regelmäßig echt heftig
reise die ich wirklich nicht für möglich
gehalten hätte bevor ich auf diesen
skurrilen trend gestoßen bin
[Musik]
der ist ja mal komplett clean hochsitzes
perfekt er ist echt einfach zur und ok
es gibt ein paar kleine unreinheiten
hier ist es nicht komplett perfekt die
beiden enden hier berühren sich auch
nicht absolut fehlerfrei und hier gibt
es definitiv punktabzug für
linienführung aber holy moly das der
perfekte gaals das ist er besser wird es
nicht also echt ne ich will jetzt nicht
sagen dass sich das gelohnt hat weil
also meinen arm fällt ab aber das hier
ist einfach kunst und zu abhängig ist
das gar nicht meine immerhin wurde auch
das gemälde von dem strich für über 40
millionen dollar verkauft aber so
überteuert kunst könnte hier noch mal
ein ganz anderes video erwarten
abonniert dafür gern den kanal dann
verpasst er das nicht checks vor allem
einen tick tock account update auch ganz
neu in betrieb genommen wurde
und ich würde sagen ich überlege mir das
was ich mit dieser tafel gestellt werde
nachts gut
[Musik]